[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the host of the very
popular ramsey network podcast called
the fine print where we teach you to
read the fine print because you know the
rule there is if you don't you get
screwed and uh george shows you all that
uh episode or season one is in the books
working on episode of season two coming
out soon uh before you know it and um
man we got some there's a lot of people
out there that uh need information so
george is here to help today we're gonna
be talking about your relationships your
mental health your
job your career and of course your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it gary's with us in
san diego to start off this hour hi gary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi george great to talk to you
thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
i've got a two-part question the first
is
about incorporating um
syncing funds into the every dollar app
for for budget when you do a sinking
fund versus just having a fluctuating
budget and the second is about market
stability so i'm
baby step 7
edm
make way more than i spend monthly and
my wife and i have been using every
dollar unconsistently but we're really
focused now
and there's things like
car insurance things like that
property taxes that are several thousand
dollars that
i'm wondering do you do you set those
aside monthly in your budget or if you
have the money do you just do it every
six months or every year so that's the
first part of my question and then
secondly i know you're friends with
um glenn beck and he's talking a lot
about this great reset and everything
i'm wondering if you have any concerns
over the market and alternate strategies
like he does do you have crazy friends
[Laughter]
i've got a few crazy friends glenn's one
of them i love glenn and he's completely
out on a plank i mean he he does this
every two or three years he predicts the
end of the world and um i made a rule
when i went on radio i'm not going to
predict the end of the world and if
glenn's going to predict the end of the
world he and i are going to be friends
that disagree
so no i don't think that the world is
coming to an end um uh you know if it
does then it will but i'm not going to
i'm not adjusting my investments and i
never have
in any of the crisises and the
geopolitical upheaval that there's been
i've always just kept investing and kept
investing and cap investing and those
the only ones that get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the ride so george what about
sinking funds well i was just going to
mention on that part on top of not
getting hurt on the ride you also kept
your sanity and that's an important part
of this equation you're suggesting maybe
glenn didn't no i'm kidding we love
glenn i'm k we joke all the time he is a
great guy he's a wonderful person i mean
i really like him uh but he just he gets
crazy sometimes man and this end of the
world prediction stuff is one of those
times so i sleep better at night yeah he
went off on the gold run a few years ago
getting everybody onto gold and of
course you know i don't do that so i got
a lot of friends that i really love them
and respect their intellect but disagree
with their ideas and so that's all this
is sinking funds let's talk about that
i'll tell you how i do it my personal
every dollar budget and dave can tell me
i've been doing it wrong all these years
but i have a i have a whole category
called funds that's wrong
i just list them all out and i divide it
by 12. so i pay all my insurance
premiums yearly because it saves money
and so if it's 600 bucks i go all right
we got to put 50 bucks in that syncing
fund category every month and that's
going to get set aside in my account so
that when that time comes the money
comes out and i didn't bat an eyelash
here's the the sinking funnel on
miniature savings accounts to cover
christmas because it comes every year in
december they don't move it so you got
to get ready right it's the old
christmas club account it's just built
into your budget as well now gary i do
want to that's exactly how i would do it
99 of the time i want to acknowledge
though that you said you're an everyday
millionaire you have a huge income
you're completely debt-free on baby step
seven so you've got substantial cash
flow what's your household income
so
it's different this year so i'm
retired and my
take home retirement guaranteed income
gross is 15 000 a month and i have a uh
okay so if you have a if you have a four
thousand dollar item that pops up once a
year
you just put it in your budget right
so yeah you don't have to save up do i
need you don't have to save up for
christmas making fifteen thousand
dollars a month you can just go freaking
by christmas
right got it yeah that's what i was
doing yeah you put that in the budget
that's what you do when you get to this
level now the the purpose of having the
sinking fund is not to nerd out on every
detail it's to not have an expense sneak
up on you that leaves you without food
money that month
because you got oh my god i gotta pay my
property taxes i have no money and i
haven't saved up any to get ready and
they're due you know but in my case you
know
we're obviously baby steps seven people
too and so i don't have a sinking fund
for my property taxes i just write a
check when it comes up because i can fit
it into my income like you can gary and
so you don't have to do the sinking fund
but if you've got something that's big
enough
that you experience an algae you know
it's like ah when that when that hits in
your monthly budget then you probably
should have saved up some to get ready
for it with a little miniature
named savings account we call them
sinking funds and it helps to know when
those are coming up because sometimes
you're like i don't know when my premium
comes out every year so it's good to
have that and have the dates but like
you're saying you've got a buffer in the
checking account when you get to a place
like baby step 7 until you're out there
like that i mean when you're in baby
steps one through six and all and you're
still fighting to pay off the house
you're you're still you're not running
with big lumps of cash laying around i
mean you're running it all those cow all
those dollars have names and they're
going everywhere you need to use syncing
funds in that case always
and the classic one is oh i had to run
christmas on a credit card because i
forgot it was in december you know it
snuck up on me like they move it they
don't move it
so that's that's what that's about but
um but man you've obviously done a
wonderful job congratulations gary very
well done
michelle's in seattle hi michelle
welcome to the ramsey show
hi there thank you so much for taking my
call it's an honor to speak with you you
too what's up
well we
we are going to retire in the next seven
ish years my husband's a firefighter so
we have a pension we're very lucky
and we just had the opportunity to sell
our house for about 1.1 which is crazy
pants in this area
we only know about 500 so we're kind of
thinking that we should take this
opportunity right now and even if we
need to rent for the next five to seven
years
then at least we can pay off all of our
debt which is about a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars okay sure household
yell at me
about 175 000 and we feel like we have
no money it's really sad yeah
well you get on tight budget and get
your debt paid off no i wouldn't sell
your house
i mean you it's a 1.1 million house is
not a super expensive house in seattle
i mean it's a nice it's a nice house but
it's not a 10 million dollar house
it's not a hard house to sell you'll be
able to sell that house in seven years
when you get ready to sell it and you
will have lost out on all the
appreciation between now and then
[Music]
i think you can pay off your debt with
the income you have yeah you can stay
the course get on your titan budget here
and beans and rice and let's get this
stinking bud you may need to sell your
car
but i wouldn't sell my house unless you
hate your house and want to move anyway
now if you want to do that that's fine
but selling it because the market's hot
i you know i wouldn't do that unless
you've got a very unusual property
and you know you're needing to walk out
of it and this is a great time to do
that but this this is not 1.1 million in
seattle is not like crazy you can get
that that's
not i think you need tighten up your
budget sell your car maybe this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
well we all know time is important it's
actually more precious than money
it's more precious than shiny toys or
getting a certificate at work
and like spending money from an account
when you don't know how much is in there
we never know how much time we have left
so if you could do one thing that would
make the time you have left worthwhile
would you do it well of course you would
you got to make that dash between the
two numbers on the gravestone count
right hey we get that and we want to
help you do everything you can to be
well that's why we're partnering with
betterhelp and we're going to give you a
month of free one-on-one weekly therapy
when you pre-order a copy of john
delony's new book dr john dolone's new
book is own your past change your future
and your free
month of one-on-one therapy is a part of
pre-ordering the book the book comes out
in april and we always have a
bag of goodies that go with a book
launch to get you to order them
pre-order and we bribe you to pre-order
them because it helps with our marketing
and this is the biggest bribe we've ever
done it's pretty incredible it's a great
deal for a 20 book you get better help
for a month included wow
and of course you get the ebook in the
audio book too in the audiobook the
first chapter is out on delony's
podcast i listened to it yesterday yeah
they released that for free as voiced by
the author and he didn't do a bad job
he's got a good voice he's got a he's
got a passable voice yeah yeah it's
usually kind of a batman vibe
well he's always had a batman vibe but
yeah the voice worked out and it's you
can listen to it some audio books read
by the author shouldn't be yeah are you
you're looking at me like it was a
personal attack no i'm not i'm just
having a conversation with you george my
gosh
you're so sensitive i like to listen to
your audiobooks while we're so yeah
thank you george and i'm highlighting
everything and you and you and you yeah
you you and you do everything exactly
right get a gold star including brown
nosing so uh yeah ramsay solutions.com
own your past change your future mike's
in buffalo hey mike welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
calling greatly appreciate it sure man
what's up
um well i'll try to make this as as as
quick as possible um big fan of yours um
i uh i wish my life looked like i was a
big fan of source um
basically the nuts and bolts of it right
now is that we've got a
uh a credit card judgment against us
the original debt was about fifteen
thousand they're coming after us for
about twenty thousand
um
after fees and interests
this is from discover
and
i'm trying to figure out what to do
they're trying to
well they're mistakenly saying that i'm
earning about four times what i actually
earn
in order to try to take
10 of my income
um
we've got a friend who's an attorney
who's trying to help us sort through
that and
you know
stave that off but that's kind of a
band-aid we just recently got our tax
return which is about five thousand
dollars
and
um
you know we're trying to figure out
what's the best thing to do with that
given our current situation
okay
what's your household income
um well my um my wife brings in
um i forget exactly it's around 50 000
annually i'm
currently the stay-at-home dad um i
do work a couple of part-time jobs that
don't make a ton that's just basically
you know to
help with essentials and bills and how
do you know things here and there
i've got three uh one is eight one's
five and one's three how did you get
this far behind
oh boy
so
a while back with that particular card
um
we had
runs and things up on it like our
honeymoon um
paid it off with a
a refinance on our house how long have
you been married was
uh close to ten years now okay we don't
need to go all the way back to the
honeymoon how'd you get behind on your
discover card in recent history
okay well i mean it wasn't recent it was
several years ago now okay okay that's
fine all right here's what that's that's
what i was trying to do that's the
number i was trying to get so we're good
okay all right so here's the deal
um
number one the discover card problem is
not the problem it's the symptom
of the fact that your income is low in
this house
you're gonna have to make some different
decisions on careers
term yes i'm trying to figure out how to
do that yeah you're going to have to you
don't have to it's time it's past time
to figure it out and this is a great
time to be looking for a job and a great
time to be getting a job both of you
maybe your wife gets a better job maybe
you get a job i don't know but we're
gonna have to do something here because
you've got three little kids and you're
living uh considerably below the average
household income in america in buffalo
which is not a cheap place to live
so
i mean we did get lucky on our house we
live outside of buffalo don't try to
talk yourself out of this dude you have
an income problem no no yeah okay i
don't care how lucky you got it you
didn't get lucky enough to pay your
bills
so right and part of it is you got three
mouths to feed you don't have a lot of
money coming in so we've got to get that
going we've got to get organized and get
on a budget we'll help you do all of
that as well
um
now as far as dealing with discover
here's the thing
are you sure you're dealing with
discover how you're probably not they
probably sold that debt haven't they
uh
i think so we were getting calls from
some ah okay the agency that's what i
thought
a debt that hasn't been paid on in this
long and they actually did sue you and
actually did get a judgment you're
saying
that's that's what it looks like yeah
unless they're sending us just flat out
and false
you know information
uh but it looks like it's stamped by our
local county sheriff's office okay
probably is and i doubt they i doubt
they'd go that far so debt buyers on old
credit card debt pay about a nickel on
the dollar
okay and so they probably paid a
thousand dollars for this twenty
thousand dollar debt
so i would offer them five thousand
dollars as settlement in full in cash
i don't have any more than that i'm
broke i have three kids we don't make
any money over here this is my tax
return and i will give it to you but i
will only give it to you there's other
people wanting this money i'm behind
with everybody i'm getting ready to go
bankrupt a few people if i can't work
this out and i'm and you know and just
really whine and play a bad country song
in the radio right there in their ear
about how bad your life is and because
it is
and i got five thousand dollars and you
guys better take that while the getting
is good and you get it in writing from
them that this is settlement in full and
then you wire them the money no
electronic access to your checking
account do not give them any numbers of
any kind do not give them where she
works don't give them any information
make them find everything the hard way
but they'll settle this because they
probably got a grand in the debt and
they'll probably take the five and walk
they're not going to in one conversation
you're going to bow up and be have a
little gravitas
all right but you can do that
two rules in writing
no electronic access to your checking
account
okay right now that solves the immediate
fire in the kitchen
but now we've got to figure out what why
we've been cooking with grease like this
and what's causing this right so yeah
and you got to get down under this and
fix the whole thing because you guys
have been wallowing around in financial
stress and it's affecting how you feel
about yourself it's affecting your
relationship and your marriage unless
you're not a human unless you're
psychotic it's affecting all of those
things it did when i went broke sure and
i about killed each other
yeah
mike do you have any other debt other
than the credit card
uh yeah i mean we both have student
loans
we have a mortgage we have um
one other card that's in collections
for a much smaller amount um it's closer
to like five or six thousand
um
but uh
they you know they haven't mentioned
anything for us on that um and then we
have a car loan that's around
i think there's something like seven or
eight thousand left on it okay
well we're gonna get we're gonna put you
into financial peace university
and sign you guys up you and your wife
need to go through this together if you
can find a local church that's doing it
jump in there if not just do it online
with us
and get in some of the groups embrace
every detail of that
and assume like i did when i went broke
when i was 28 many years ago
assume that everything you're doing
right now is wrong and you should be
doing the opposite
because your life sucks man but i don't
want it i want you to win the last 10
years yeah i want you to win and you've
got to turn this around yeah so you hang
on we'll get you signed up and and you
call me back if you need some more help
george and i'll be here we're going to
be here for you we're going to walk with
you because it's scary as crud where you
live right now and i don't i don't want
you to be there anymore i remember it
it's not fun
and you can get there you can win you
can turn this around check out a local
church and get plugged in get your
marriage going make sure you're getting
your bills paid get this settled and get
it out of your life you can turn this
around we can show you how
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave ramsey your host
this is the ramsay show brian and jamie
are with us in san bernardino california
it says on my screen you guys are debt
free congratulations
thank you thank you for having us cool
how much debt did you pay off
we paid off 325 000
in uh 29 months wow
and your range of income during that
time
uh we started out at about 225 000
and uh last year brian doubled his
income so that's what
you broke up brian double his income and
what
brian we started about 225 000 and then
last year brian did really well he's in
so he did really well and doubled his
income last year which helped us pay off
the debt
so i'm sorry your household income last
year was to what then did
it went from 225 to 450
yes okay all right so brian is the only
income i'm getting it okay that's what i
was trying to figure out good way to go
guys what in the world do you do for a
living dude
i'm in sales actually jamie jamie's uh
in the medical industry so she also has
a um a career her occupational um is in
medicals
oh okay okay so
so it was your household income 450 did
i get that right
yeah
so what kind of debt was the 325
so we had um we had two cars that we had
to pay off we had a truck my car and
then we also had an rv
and then our house has paid off as well
we just paid that off this morning
talking to weird people
so what's what is this california house
worth
what's the house worth
so right now um maybe
800 to
850. okay wow very good how old are you
two
uh we're both 40. way to go and how much
to get do you have in your nest egg in
savings
so we did that's where we we did do
financial peace university and we had
savings
uh in order to pay off the house i
wanted it paid off today since we were
calling you so we did pull money out of
savings to pay that off this morning how
much do you have in your 401ks and your
retirement and that kind of stuff oh
all of that together uh
maybe four hundred thousand so you're 40
year old millionaires
where'd it go did you guys just figure
that out please tell me
there's another fifty thousand dollar
house four hundred thousand that's a
million two net worth way to go when you
say it that way yeah it's well that's
the way it's said well done
way to go you guys amazing and you make
incredible money you're doing so well
congratulations okay what started you on
this whole that's a huge lifesaver for
us okay what started you on this whole
ramsey journey thing
so dave i i've listened to you for
god 10 years over the over the
radio but
um i've always told jamie hey we should
we should look into this you know it'd
be fun to kind of
hear how to
invest as millionaires going forward and
getting that lifelong goal so um
this came up with our church and i said
you know we should do it she was
hesitant at first and i said it's i
think it was sixty dollars when we did
it um
and anyways we ended up doing that and
um she i kind of drug her through it and
the first day that she was in there she
was like why are we doing this we're not
in debt and oh i was so mad i said we
have no credit cards we don't have any
debt all we have is our house and our
cars
and
the financial piece totally changed our
mindset and then you start looking at
your bills seeing how much you pay in
interest it was shocking
jamie i'm confused you got two car loans
and you didn't see that as debt even
though the payments were going to
lenders every month talk to me about the
mindset
a lot of people say that they call and
say dave i don't have any debt except
for my cars
yeah that's that's what we said
yeah the way to go you guys so how many
classes in the financial peace
university jamie before you flipped and
said okay i'm not mad
anymore oh it was probably the third
class because the first class i still
said why are we doing this this is such
a waste of our time
yeah and it wasn't until they made us
write down our debt start a budget when
you really start looking at numbers
the reality hits you and you go oh my
gosh he's right we're broke
yeah yeah
yeah when you write down that you have
140 000 in debt it's it's it's shocking
and 29 months later house and everything
is paid for yes way to go
how's that feel
oh we're in shock still we recorded uh
us making that last payment this morning
i love it that's awesome i love it well
congratulations we're very proud of you
guys what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of debt in 29 months is
what do we tell them you said
oh you got to take financial peace you
have to do that snowball effect
ah okay
cool and also be on a budget you know i
don't think we realized how much money
was going out the door
on a monthly basis versus what we were
bringing in and we were living you know
as we considered comfortably but um the
mindset that that class gave us to
change our
our viewpoints and just roll it down has
now put us in an extremely good position
going forward yeah wow pretty amazing
way to go guys
i love it so proud of you you're
incredible very well done
all right we're going to send you a copy
of baby steps millionaires because you
are one uh maybe you can pass that on
after you read it and inspire someone
else to do what you've done i'm so proud
of you how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
it's the number one best seller we're
also sending you the number one
bestseller total money makeover so you
give that away and disturb someone's
life let's create a holy ruckus together
well done you guys i'm proud of you very
very cool well done all right brian and
jamie san bernardino 325 000 paid off in
29 months making two and a quarter to
over 400
100 debt free house and everything baby
steps millionaires by the time they're
40. count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
one
two three
[Applause]
i love it
well done well done
absolutely incredible
very cool you guys very cool
that is how it's done man three lessons
in that just for everyone to know if
you're taking fpu the first sometimes i
hear the first lesson turns turns them
around but she was hardcore you got a
bad attitude it might take it two or
three
she's hardcore i mean she had the arms
folded you know and
the old body language just says i'm
pissed and i don't want to be here right
and you start to let the hair down the
arms start to spread out yeah we can do
this wait a minute wait a minute we can
do this i love it that's so good what a
great story
very very well done you guys
michelle is with us in miami florida hi
michelle welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave um
well thanks to everything that you've
taught i am now on baby step four
i have a fully funded emergency fund and
i'm saving 22 percent towards retirement
and my house is paid off yay
wow like george said to that last couple
i mounted that except for my car
[Music]
don't beat me up for that
but um the lease term is up in december
and my payoff amount is 22 000
um i just learned that the kelly blue
book trade-in value is 27 000. so i'd
like to know should i pay off this card
into the lease term or should i just cut
my losses and go find another car
i'm sorry i thought you said you could
buy it for 22 and the value is 27.
yes that would not be cutting your
losses that would be gaining
just like it you'd have to spend 27 or
you can pay this one off for 22. is that
right
that's right
therefore you're getting a 5 000
discount which is unheard of in this
market in that in that sense so do you
have the money to
to buy it
well i'd have to eat into my emergency
fund
well we're going to do that
what's your household income okay
i make 41 000. oh
no i would uh i i i i would buy the car
and turn around sell it and get
something cheaper make you make you a
five thousand dollar profit and uh then
get something that's less expensive
making 40 thousand you don't need to be
driving a thirty thousand dollar car a
lot of cars for that too much too much
from things going down in value i know
they're not going down in value at this
moment but they will be soon again it's
used cars and they always go down in
value so
no no i i would i would make the five
grand on it though and flip it and then
move into another car at that point and
they never touched that again yes ever
under any circumstances
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at aaa 825-5225
adam is with us in toronto hey adam
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing dave good man what's
up
well nothing uh well i shouldn't say
nothing quite a bit but just a little
bit of a recap back in 2016 my wife and
i did as you say stupidly zeros on the
end of it uh spent a lot and 2017 paid
off about 65 000 bucks of debt in 11
months
and i never did end up getting down for
a debt-free screen but anyway um fast
forward now in the last i guess a couple
years colbot has kind of destroyed my
industry that i'm a pilot and in canada
here it really took a bad hit it's just
kind of recovering now
and so with the stress that that kind of
brought about which brought some
marriage issues along with it and uh
life is in a really uh bad spot right
now i guess we both kind of are
and um
is not sure if she wants to work on the
marriage or what she wants to do and
we're kind of in this stalemate but in
the resulting kind of aftermath is that
she's decided that she's going to spend
however she wants to spend and kind of
uh go back to you know she's saying we
make too much money there's no way i
should have to have any restraint and so
uh kind of spending about well i'd say
about two thousand dollars a month over
what we make
and as a result of kind of depleted our
emergency fund almost down to nothing
she signed up for an elective surgery to
the tune of about ten thousand dollars
and one kind of questions on the timing
of it she just said well
i'm either either we fund it somehow
through us or i'm just gonna look at my
whole credit card do it myself
and uh and so
but every time i bring up finances to
her to uh to talk about it she says
you're obsessed with money you've got to
stop being so obsessed i'm trying to
just bring her to the reality that we're
spending more than we make and we're
kind of gradually bankrupting the family
you know we've got four young children
and uh trying to you know put money
aside for them as well and and
retirement now that we're kind of both
kind of getting back on our feet we do
make good money but uh the reality is
we're just spending way too much and she
has no desire to even talk about it
she'll still involve me every time i try
to bring it up and i'm worried that i'm
going to tip her over the edge in the
marriage if i talk too much about
finances but if i you're my marriage
well yeah that's the thing if i i feel
like i'm kind of giving the drunk a
drink
you didn't hear me
you don't hear me your your marriage is
already gone
yeah well i mean she she doesn't give
indications that she doesn't want to
make it worse no she does that no she
does not ready
no no no she doesn't
people that do the things that say the
things that she's doing have no desire
for this marriage to continue
yeah when you say things like if you
don't go if you don't uh
pay for this ten thousand dollar i'm
just gonna put it on a credit card screw
you you don't have a vote
this is not a marriage this is not
someone that has a marriage anymore that
wants to work at all and so what i would
do if i were in your shoes is the two
you would say i'm going to go see a
marriage counselor
and it's either going to be with you on
how we learn to get back on the same
page and we have a future together
that's going to include us both being
grown-ups um and if you want to go with
that that's fine if not the marriage
counselor is going to instruct me on how
to bring this marriage to an end
yeah we have done some counseling and
just work a couple times and just trying
to get her to come back to it is the
hard part and she's very reluctant yeah
you're begging her to do stuff then she
you know and she has no desire she's
obstinate she's angry and she's done
she's done the marriage is over
i mean it's tough to say that because
she does see that she still does she
wants she's lying what she says is not
what she's doing and so that's the
problem yeah
and again people that want their
marriage to work do not behave the way
that she is behaving
yes i would agree okay so
yes
elective surgery for ten thousand
dollars when you're broke and the
family's in financial stress
that's so selfish and asinine i can't
even put words to it yeah i know that's
that's kind of my thought too
it just is it's a fact it's not an
opinion
it's that that is her screaming in your
face that she's done
yeah
yeah i know i don't really like to think
of it that way obviously because it's
not a nice outcome for anybody and this
is this mess and i think
i'm not sure you did it i think you're
just the one that's going to admit it
yeah now i would agree with you going
back a couple months that she was done
and however she's had some influential
people in her life in the last month or
two
that have helped bring her around her
attitude has changed well then that
would involve you guys getting in a good
getting with a good marriage counselor
immediately yes but then she needs to
turn into action
yes and she has admitted that that is an
option i i did confront her about it
about a couple weeks ago and she has i
said this is what i want to do i had
some referrals for her focus on the
family and she said
yes that is an option and so i'm just
kind of trying to
not push her because she doesn't know i
am going to pressure
it's time to push her it's time to push
you
the house is on fire
it's burning down around you
get out of the house
push somebody
yeah i am i definitely am i'm bringing
stuff up fairly regularly but you know
kind of teetering on the edge of not
wanting to push her over one side to get
her her emotional side to engage i want
to honey what you think is being nice is
not nice you think you're you think you
can beg and be sweet and cause this to
happen and it's i'm not asking you to be
mean to her but you're acting like that
you can beg her into wanting to do this
she has to stand up square her shoulders
and say i'm going to re-engage in this
marriage and re-engage as two adults on
how to run our household and she has to
do that under the heading of a therapist
and the two of you learn to work
together again you cannot beg her to
behave
yes i agree with that totally it's you
know i i can't change her she has to
decide to do it it's a matter of you
know we're trying to get you know
obviously lots of prayer and other
friends of influence you have to get
around her i absolutely change your
heart
what
and she needs to be going and if she's
not going then we need to know what that
we need to admit what that says
yeah okay but all this there is not a
financial technique that's a problem
here
the financial problems in the financial
spending are all about her obstinance
and you trying to talk talk your way
around it to where it's all somehow okay
it's not okay
it's not okay
it doesn't work that way and so if uh
whitney uh decided to start just start
telling george what she was gonna do
george would have a thing have a thing
where you know here's what we're gonna
do i don't tell sharon what to do and
tell me what to do we sit down we talk
about like two adults we devise a plan
on how we're gonna do the calendar how
we're gonna do the budget how we're
gonna live our life we work together
towards common goals this is called a
quality relationship in your marriage uh
but when people start throwing around
they're just like i'm gonna do whatever
i want to do and they get the all head
bobbin thing going and you shouldn't
have got married then it's you know you
you've got a mess on your hands and
you've got to go back and try to try to
learn how to be married and it that
takes both people and you can't beg
someone to behave you cannot control
someone else's behavior your behavior is
the only thing you can control
and you put in a situation to go if you
do this then you're choosing to opt out
if you do this you're choosing to opt in
but i can't make you choose that's the
only thing you can do is present options
to her but this idea of i'm gonna let
her be go run our family and bankrupt us
so that by being nice and letting her do
stupid butt stuff that's going to ruin
our family then that and causes her to
go to counseling that's that's a that's
a false narrative that doesn't work
that's if the auspices for her going to
counseling is so that is because she got
bribed
by you you're putting up with a bunch of
crap then that no that is not how you
start rebuilding this thing
so now you guys need you desperately
both of you need to sit in the
counseling counselor's room immediately
or you're not going to make it and the
spending stuff is just i'm not we're not
going i'm not going along with it
and if you don't like it i'm just part
of what we can talk to the counselor
about or it's part of what we can talk
to the divorce judge about one of the
two it's one of the two but i'm not
going along with this
because it's not right and i'm not
suggesting you leave today i'm
suggesting that the two of you get into
the counselor's office
four years ago but right now for sure
it's the only best option best time to
plant an oak tree 10 years ago next best
time is today oh yeah that's a great
quote she sees him as basically a
doormat at this point because she knows
well i'm just going to do what i want
he's not going to tell me off yeah he's
not going to have the conflict you have
to stop being scared that you're going
to cause the marriage to end
by
pushing by pushing the marriage to
succeed
that's that that's
that is not going to work it's not going
to work you're going to end up nowhere
but bankruptcy court and divorce court
at the same time
oh man sorry so sorry what a horrible
thing you're going through i sure hope
she comes around i hope the two of you
get in counseling and i hope it saves
your marriage but
you know you participating in crazy is
not going to make crazy go away
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships about
your money
about your career your job
about
mental health whatever it is you want to
talk about we're here to help you the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
two
john is with us john's in chicago to
start off this hour hi john how are you
hello dave thank you for all that you do
let me say that first well thank you sir
how can we help i don't i can't think of
a single program that affects people's
lives so positively okay my wife and i
are business owners and we work together
and have for over 20 plus years
let me uh paint the scenario you ask the
questions you feel you need to know okay
we purchased about three acres of
property uh that the intent for this uh
acreage in the in the end is that uh
we parked campers and and uh rv vehicles
this is my retirement job i'm never
gonna retire i know that she knows that
but i have to have a plan for something
i can physically do
when i get to be much older so that's my
physical toleration limit i felt
having said that we bought the land uh
we bought it at about 4.2 percent
and
we also
rent
garage space on another property
now
we're always going we're always going to
build a steel building on the land that
we own
and move the business over there to
avoid that rent
but here's the question that i'm not
sure
if i build the steel building it's going
to cost me let's just say a hundred
thousand dollars
and i'm going to build that steel
building with cash
or
do i take that hundred thousand dollars
and pay off the loan for the land
and then save up enough again to pay
cash for the building but then the whole
time i'm renting the other one so it's
like this uh not sure what really the
best thing to do is question what's your
income that's kind of where i'm at
uh
our business grosses now i know that's
not your question but if you don't
understand what business it is
we're going to personally net about 250
000 a year okay all right
all right well it sounds like you sounds
like you could build a building fairly
quickly if you paid off the
land if i pay if we paid off the land i
think we could build the building in
another two years so maybe
faster than that it's only a hundred
thousand dollars
right i understand exactly what you're
saying but we we've gotten rid of all of
our debt except we do have uh less than
a hundred thousand left on our original
mortgage and we have one vehicle but we
were the in just in two years we were
the first pick now we're looking at the
third peg okay i'm sorry you don't
follow what did you say about you have a
car debt yeah we have one truck in the
business all the other trucks are paid
for all the other equipment's paid for
okay we have one truck in the business
and then um we don't have any other
retail debt we don't have any credit
card debt nothing like that just how
much do you owe on the truck
uh about 35 000 okay and you have how
much in cash right now
our we have cash of about 20 000
where was the hundred thousand going to
come from to build the building
in the contracts that were
in pla that are in place now for our
business we have several years of
contractual work so the future right is
going to make this
future revenue that's correct so you
were just going to cash flow it is what
you're saying oh my gosh our cash flow
is just insane now but that creates a
problem that you have to be more aware
of you know you can get lazy
what's on the mortgage your primary yes
about 99 000
okay and then you also have a hundred
thousand oat on the land
uh we have about 150 on the land we paid
the land down about 25 in the last few
years 35 on a truck 100 on our house
and 150 on the land
yes and a 250 income
yes
all right what i would do is about 20
and about 20 in cash your shortest
distance between where you are and
wealthy is to become debt free
okay and then cash flow whatever and
along the way your cash flowing the
business but you're also cashflowing
whatever needs so i'm gonna get the
truck paid off as soon as i can i'm
gonna get uh i'm gonna get my house paid
off as quick as i can then i'm gonna pay
off the land and then i'm gonna build
the building with cash
you got it do you have an emergency fund
or is that 20k it yeah
that's what the 20k is and and we just
weren't sure if paying rent was really
the best thing to do during all this
time yes yeah yeah you rent because
you're because you still have debt
yes okay yeah that's actually a good
answer
he's surprised that's the uh
well that's the
the thing is this you get caught up in
the it's like um you know it's it's the
same dichotomy that people say well i
pay 600 or paid
1600 a month in rent
on my home so i might as well buy a
house because the payments are only 1700
you know and and they're not the same
they're not the same that's a again it's
a false narrative that people use to
justify or to rationalize buying a house
when you're not ready to buy a house
because you're broke and so
um
well the payment's the same yeah but
home ownership's more expensive than
non-home ownership so
and and and
the the
retail okay let's put 100 000 in the
middle of the table
all it's going to make you is the saved
rent the fact that you don't have to
rent the thing anymore the building if
you used it to build a building you see
your return on that 100 000 is not 100
000 in one year
so it takes a while for this stuff to
work out and i i kind of know that
because i've done that here i mean i've
dumped uh
a couple of hundred million dollars into
this campus
that um that this company then rents
back from me
but uh but it's uh
you know the rate of return is good uh
reasonable
on the money invested but it's not like
i get that money back every year that i
put into this it'll be years and years
and years and years before i get that
money back out of this place
i own an asset but it's not you know
it's not like okay you build a hundred
thousand dollar building and save you a
hundred thousand dollars it doesn't it's
not it'll be years
before the break even on that so that's
that's what and doing the math on okay
if we free up that truck payment then we
free up your mortgage payment and you
make 250k yeah
now we can save up and buy that steel
building like nothing
and pay off the pay off the acreage so
if i were in your shoes i would cut my
lifestyle down to nothing i pay off my
house in my truck this year
and i pay off the building or the land
the next year and i build a building the
next year
now the question is he's got 20k there
that's his emergency fund but he's also
got the cart
i don't know what he's doing with the
business so i'm a little bit worried
that that business having no cash at all
could be running a 250 000 top line our
gross profit or whatever he's running
there
so i'm
honest at home i'd take him down to a
thousand but in the business i might let
him have some retained earnings so i
just kind of left that alone uh in this
scenario if it would have paid the truck
off completely i would have i might have
reached over and grabbed it
but
i'm going to let it sit there for now
and use this cash flow to clean this
mess up if i'm him
john thank you thank you for being a
listener and thank you for your kind
words we appreciate it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host i am so excited smart conference
is back this fall october 22nd we're
bringing this world-class event to
dallas texas you're gonna spend a whole
day getting smarter
we're gonna give you the tools and the
inspiration you need to be smarter in
every area of your life you'll go home
believing you can
meet your goals you can build wealth you
can grow as a leader you can heal from
mental health and relationship struggles
you can get the job of your dreams
we're bringing the best teachers and
thought leaders joining me will be
ramsey personalities rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman george campbell
christina ellis pedro lattore and
special guests craig and amy groschel
will be there speaking on marriage
craig is the pastor of lifechurch.tv
over in oklahoma city the largest church
in america today and he is an incredible
he and amy are incredible communicators
so this is going to be an incredible
all-day event smart conference october
22nd in dallas
the early bird prices are gone
tickets are selling very rapidly smart
conference traditionally sells out very
fast it's been a while since we've done
one because of all the garbage we've all
been through but now we're back at doing
live events again big time and excited
about it we've missed doing them we've
missed being out there in these cities
with you guys george this is gonna be
fun it's legitimately my favorite event
and i learned so much i'm out there in
the crowd taking notes because these
powerhouse speakers are just bringing
such inspiration motivation education
and so i want everyone to be there it's
a party i mean you get you know six 8
000 people in a room after what we've
been through the last few years and
we're just celebrating we're having a
great time well and we're you're going
to leave just exhausted and smart
that's something it's drinking from the
firehouse that's it man taste of
everything we do here at ramsay
solutions so ramsay solutions dot com
slash events october 22nd in dallas get
your tickets now
before they are gone it will sell out
early uh again
you've seen the football games on
television and everything else things
are selling out quickly and easily these
days and you do not want to miss this go
ahead and get your tickets now at
ramseysolutions.com
events james is in michigan hi james
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you guys today thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i i first want to say thank you um
i had a nasty divorce two years ago
that's when i discovered you guys
everything you do um i went from a
camper payment and a furniture payment
all the way down to uh baby step five
saving uh 15 per kid and a 529 plan wow
so yeah again thank you
um i guess my question is um i i saw one
unexpected uh side effect of this was my
kids are very observant my daughter is
14 now my son's 12.
um you know i was getting all these
questions dad why are you paying cash
for this everyone uses their card all
these weird weird things so i've been
kind of using that as a learning
opportunity for them
to kind of set them up to manage money
better when they're older
now it's to the point where my daughter
who is very ambitious uh wants to get
her first job after school um you know
good grades pending of course but uh
i i really want to lead her in a way to
where you know she could start saving
now and just build these habits early so
i i don't know how to go about this um
do do the baby steps apply to a teenager
like dude do i set her up with a um
you know like a custodial ira or what do
you guys typically recommend for this
sort of
situation
well i think it's awesome that you're
doing that and that she's seeing this
stuff going i want to do this and not
being pushed away from it so uh you know
there's there's three things that you
can do with money and if she understands
that she's gonna be okay give save and
spend and we've got her you know the
junior piggy bank and maybe a little
beyond her at her age but if she can
learn to make money and then manage said
money by giving a little bit saving a
little bit spending a little bit she's
gonna be okay
yeah you don't have to get super
sophisticated and do custodial iras or
anything at this stage of the game for
her to learn
uh george is exactly right let's just
make sure she's building the muscles
appropriate to a 14 year old
you can invest some
you can
give some and you can enjoy or spend
some
and you need to do some of that out of
each paycheck and no the baby steps do
not apply to a 14 year old uh she's got
a she's got a place to live she's got
food that's her dad's job uh but her job
is just to learn
how to handle money and to build these
muscles in these three areas and then
they can get progressively more
sophisticated but we're not trying to um
i mean when my when dave ramsey's kids
were 18
they could not tell you
uh
you know
super nerdy details about investments
they knew a general understanding of
mutual funds and they knew about
generosity and they knew about not
spending money you didn't have
and that was about it and they then they
were ready to go to college with that
now you know you could take it a little
bit further if you want i'll send you a
copy of the book rachel and i did smart
money smart kids which is all about
teaching parents how to teach them or
how to teach their kids how to handle
money and it's all about age appropriate
um you know three-year-old gets a
different version of give save spend
than a 14 year old gets but uh but yeah
i don't you don't have to do a bunch of
fancy fancy stuff it's just a matter of
answer her questions put the stuff in
front of her and you know if she'll
learn to be intentional with the money
she earns that's a big plus george is
exactly right and at that age i mean our
ramsay education team does a great job
our personal finance curriculum is now
at 48 of high schools and so i don't
know if they have that at her school if
not we've got a homeschool course on our
website that you can jump on to but
something like that could be a good
resource for her if she does want to do
a little more of a deep dive yeah she
might actually love going through that
amy is in san francisco hi amy welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure i'm shocked about through
actually i've called so many times well
i'm honored you did how can we help
okay well a few months ago i was
searching on youtube um and i typed in
uh my husband controls all the finances
and i came across you
and since then i've been binge listening
to you and your daughter rachel and i've
learned been learning so much
in changing
many things just really just learning
and then making some pretty big changes
so i'm at the very beginning and just
working on getting out of debt
i've i've been married for about 14
years and i have three kids and my
husband and i are currently separated
um
so my question is
it's kind of a relationship question but
also a financial is both he's a
financial advisor for morgan stanley
and
we never combined our finances we both
came to the marriage with finances
and he bought our home a year and a half
before we got married
uh and finances were always a really
really heated topic for him and so
i very ignorantly spent down
um
my
being the separate money that i had
coming into our marriage
because i never had access to our
community mess to our community money
um and he was really resentful that i
didn't have a job and we had three we
had our three kids kind of back to back
to back
they're barely four years apart between
zero and
all three of them were born in four
years
i know
i'm really just wanting to hear
um
just what you would have to say to this
situation i'm i'm just super overwhelmed
i'm sorry
sorry for what you're going through um
this is this guy's not a nice guy
no he's he's not
well he is if i do it no he you know he
has a mean streak
and uh
he's very controlling and he's not a
nice guy
and it wasn't just money as everything
else too
right
yeah yeah yeah but it was the money was
always the trigger yeah but that's that
it always it always is yeah
the um i'm sorry
so um
you know i think what you guys are going
to have to decide is if you're if the
marriage is going to stay together and
if it is it's going to have a whole new
set of terms
and that is that we're going to be
sharing everything
and we both get a vote
um you don't get the only vote
i don't think this guy's going to come
to the table on that so i don't i don't
have a good i don't think he is either
so i don't think your marriage is going
to continue i think you have to learn
how to what this looks like for you
personally going forward from here yeah
what's the future look like for you as a
single mom
uh with huge child support and alimony
from him and i don't know what your
rights in california are to this house
that prior to marriage your divorce
attorney i'll have to tell you that
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage andy and nicki
are with us hey guys how are you
good yeah doing good welcome where do
you guys live
st louis missouri all right well welcome
to nashville it's good to have you guys
so fun how much data have you paid off
uh we paid off thirty thousand dollars
cool how long did that take it took us
five months good for you
and your range of income during that
time
110 000 okay good what do y'all do for a
living
i'm a teacher
and i work in human resources for who
a manufacturing company good good for
you guys wow excellent so what kind of
debt was this 30 000
it was uh primarily student loans and a
water filtration system for our home of
course
of course
i love it all right good for you guys
how long you been married
12 years okay so what happened uh five
months ago that you go okay we're not
doing this anymore we're cleaning this
up boom just like that
yeah so
we in probably the first year of our
marriage somebody told us about you know
the dave ramsey plan and actually let us
borrow a book and everything and i kind
of like on my own i didn't read it i
just went to the how do i make a budget
and so i
used an excel spreadsheet i made us a
budget
um
and that was kind of
it just stayed on the excel spreadsheet
and we actually did the envelope system
yeah we did the envelope a little bit a
little bit here and there
um we were not tracking all of our
purchases um we weren't counting all of
our receipts and so we were just just
just just just doing it loosely sticking
to the budget and paying extra on our
debt we always had that we had student
loans we had cars our entire marriage
we've had debt so
and so
um so you were pretty much ish
yeah exactly and ish is a wish
and so what happened by myself
so what happened that flipped it five
months ago
um i was mowing the grass and i wanted
to listen to a new podcast and uh so i
uh
started searching for something new you
know and obviously when we
knew who you were as you know growing up
in church and everything we've heard the
name dave ramsey i just didn't know a
whole lot about it
i
found the podcast just scrolling i
started listening to these debt free
screams and and just all the advice and
and what your future can look like if
you take hold of it and uh it was just
very very eye-opening
and i was convinced i just became very
convinced that you know we can be free
of this he was like we can be
millionaires yeah she didn't believe me
i don't think so
where's the guy that just went to cut
the grass
i was like we're already doing it i'm
paying extra on our student loans when i
can so right so and she has been the
number person i'm not a numbers person
at all you know and i brought this to or
we started listening to the podcast
together
um decided that we were just going to do
this we're going to get on board and
start hearing all these stories of
people just getting this intensity
and and fighting this battle basically
just just to
knock this out i was like this can
happen we should be able to do this
there's no reason we can't
um so did you just need that bigger why
that bigger vision of like what are we
doing we're just looking at what's
happening next week we need to look at
what could happen 10 20 years from now
well it was that and
we weren't doing as much as we could we
there was no gazelle intensity it was
just like we'll do actually here like
where we can
so i want to retire yeah
it was the long-term vision and the
intentionality yeah so that got you guys
fire i mean you went pretty hard at this
30k in five months making 110 i mean you
this is rice and beans what were you
guys doing
it it didn't feel that way actually you
know i knew that we did have um you know
when we first got married we were
combined income 30 grand you know we
were on some government assistance you
know we had a baby a six week old baby
hardly any money you know um it was it
was hard um we had some in savings too
that we were able to pour into it
because we really weren't doing the plan
we had how much was in savings about 12
000. okay so 12 000 which left you 18 to
knock it out in in the five months yeah
that makes a whole lot more sense i
gotta i gotta ask how much is a water
filtration system these days
it wasn't what they range they range we
i think we financed about it was seven
thousand
yeah it was crazy oh my goodness
those sales pitches are very convincing
yeah they are yeah so you never let them
into your house it's gone now
wow you got rid of it or did you just
paint
it
that's gone
no that's gone we're keeping that good
water oh man that's right wow way to go
guys
how's it feel
really good yeah it feels very very
freeing you know i did this really fast
but very intense yeah yeah yeah i think
it was really important for me to kind
of like connect this to like a spiritual
truth um and that like really gave me
this umph behind it um
you know this
uh i i really like um
what it says in the psalms that god has
determined the stars and called them
each by name and i i thought you know
when we
can label inc in every single dollar and
give every single dollar a name just
like the name of the app that's what
this is all about is taking every single
dollar
and uh the zero point budget and
creating that um you know when we
apply biblical principles to our
practical lives you know i really feel
like we reflect the image of god amen
beautiful amen
it's well done it's well done that's
what it took for me i had to have the
same exact thing because i had all the
head knowledge and i still went broke
you know because i was doing stupid butt
stuff and but i finally had to go okay
this is god's ways of doing it and the
answer to everything else is no that's
the only answer that way and i it was an
act of faith and that that flipped it
and i think the people that have the
fastest most dramatic turnarounds have
an element
of spiritual spirituality and psychology
and a relational shift in their marriage
as well those three things come together
it just pours gas on this whole idea and
you can go
you go right through it and you and the
thing about this is i don't even have to
ask you this you'll never go back
no there's nothing there's nobody that
can sell you anything on that ever again
it'll never happen uh you're done you
you i but by the way you described that
that's yeah that's that's what goes with
that package so you know you're not
going to fall off the wagon yeah and we
just totally agreed
the whole time you know i mean there was
you know i was i was uh selling plasma
doing some uber and on the side a little
bit so i taught summer school for the
first time in my career wow wow
you guys got after it and already got it
done that's awesome we're very proud of
you who was your biggest cheerleader
outside the two of you
yeah so definitely um my wife's
parents and they're here with us today
mom and dad yeah
yeah um
and uh you know we had some other
support you know um from just people
have done it you know someone from work
and um you know her and her husband had
gone through it and got debt-free and
um so that was uh just good moral
support you know friends that supported
us so
very cool good for you guys
how's it feel now that you're free
awesome very very good never going back
that's for sure amen amen and you
cashflowed those amazing t-shirts to say
three two one we're debt-free too yeah
because she makes them she made them
nice there we go all right
yeah this is cool it really has enabled
us to um you know i'm gonna go back to
school for a master's degree and so just
just a cash flow that yeah that's not
something i ever thought i'd be able to
do you know
what are you going to study
mental health counseling oh wow love it
good for you well done man well done
all right we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you uh that's the next
chapter in your financial story for sure
you've done an incredible job and we've
got a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to somebody and stir
them up and get them going you brought
the kiddos with you what are their names
and ages let's bring them into the shot
this is yes we have noah he's ten and
tenley is six all right everybody's got
the t-shirts on everybody's ready to
rock and roll i love it way to go you
guys andy nikki noah and tinley from st
louis 30 000 bucks paid off in five
months making 110 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two
one we're dead free
i love it
wow
look at that a lot of smiles over there
a lot of dead free faces that's a lot of
fun a lot of awesome t-shirts what a
pretty cool couple there they got a lot
they got a bright future ahead of them a
lot of good stuff could about to come
their way going on for the masters
living the dream man it's amazing and
they'll be millionaires too before you
know it they will hit that goal you're
right this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here ted is
with us in boston hi ted welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so another question for you i'm going to
be starting medical school in august
and i just wanted to know your opinion
and how i should go about my finances in
regards to like what i have saved and
how much loans i should take out there
in the next 40 years
okay um well you don't have a long run a
long runway here it's pretty much here
huh
yep so how much money do you have to pay
for medical school
so
in the beginning of august i'll have
projected about 150k saved up
and uh what do you project your budget
for medical school is
so
tuition is going to be around 43 000 a
year
and cost of living will be about 33 000
a year projected
so we're talking about 76 per year
more or less yeah how many years four
four total
yep yeah uh and will you have any income
during that time
i mean i'm it depends on how i do i
might be able to do like a shift here
there a month but i'm not really
counting on working
where'd you get 150
um i'm 26 so i've been working since
more like 22 years old so i saved up wow
okay so you're um
75 000 shy right
did i do that right no i didn't do that
soon he's about 300 000 he's got 150.
yeah you're about 150 000 shy yeah
you're right yeah
so uh well you know we don't we don't
tell people to take out loans here on
this show
and so i i'm going to be scrambling and
figuring out a way to find that other
money whether it be scholarships or
fellowships or
md phd programs or whatever they are
whatever you can get into
how much of that four years are you in
residency
so the way that medicine works is you do
four years of medical school which is
straight school you're paying tuition
you're not making a dime after you
graduate your four years then you do
your residency and depending on the
specialty you choose it's anywhere from
three years to seven years right okay
all right
and so
you know your plan right now is to come
out with 300 000 or 150 in student loan
debt is that your plan
so
yes i just don't know what's the best
way to go about it i'm considering
just keeping my 150 000 in investments
and just letting that sit over the next
four years and just taking out loans
over the next four years absolutely
absolutely
that's effectively borrowing money to in
on student loans to invest it
no absolutely not no you're you're that
makes you 300 000 in student loan debt
no that's that's suicide
no i'm definitely using the 105th 150
until it's gone and during that period
of time i'm going to be trying to figure
out a way to come up with the rest of it
so there's no loans
okay so drain the whole hundred fifty oh
absolutely
absolutely i mean if you can scrounge
another thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
cut my dead gum lifestyle down i mean 33
000 a year for lifestyle while you're in
school
that's a little steep yeah i know he's
in boston which is my hometown but i
think you can you can shave that down i
don't care if you live with five dudes
whatever you have to do to shave down
that cost because that is something that
is in your control uh to an extent and
so i'm gonna be like dave said going for
those scholarships grants whatever you
can scrounge up there i'm gonna be
working a little bit i mean you can do
some work especially you're not in
school you know 40 hours a week you're
studying obviously there's still summers
there's things you can be doing to bring
in you know 10 20
grand a year the other thing i'm gonna
do is do everything i can to find
scholarship money uh it's a little it's
a lot harder to find scholarship money
for graduate work or med school or law
school but we have talked to many people
over the years that have found it and
have done it
and i would
i definitely would i'd make that my
thing so
man
and absolutely listen what
what your question does it scares me to
my bones because it tells me that in
your mind you've normalized this level
of student loan debt and it's not normal
it's financial suicide
and it takes years to undo these kinds
of mistakes
uh and so and with this kind of time by
the way everyone that starts med school
doesn't finish
and everyone that finishes does not
become a rich doctor
uh this is mythology
in this current world that we live in
and so
the set of assumptions that allow you to
go 300 000 in debt in your mind and
that's all okay is a really dangerous
narrative you're setting yourself up for
all kinds of problems alex is with us in
nashville hey alex welcome to the ramsey
show
hey there dave i'm so thankful that god
uh graced us with you and your team in
the ministry that you all have we
appreciate you so much and george uh
hang on there the uh youtube trolls
don't listen to them you're killing
brother i appreciate the encouragement
thank you alex
hey i'm a 27 year old pastor in the
nashville area
my wife and i we have one one child who
is almost two
and uh we're in baby step two we have a
very significant amount of debt uh 107
000
and uh we paid off significant amounts
since december but we are seeking um
i want to seek wisdom from you guys on
if it is the right time for us to have a
second child we really want a second
child but we are gazelle intense on baby
step two yes so uh
it's always the right time to have a
baby
it's always the right time babies are
awesome
there's nothing better we just know
obviously
if you give me these same numbers and
said you already had eight kids i'd tell
you to
take a chill pill and let's let's get
the cadet paid off but you got one baby
and another one on the way i don't we do
not tell people to stop life because of
debt uh you know not we don't tell young
couples not our couples to not get
married because of debt we don't tell
people to not have babies because of
debt ever never have in 30 years of
doing this show
those are decisions between you your
spouse and god and um
you know the the fact that you're aware
that you're bringing a child into this
situation and that you know with two
little babies you guys are gonna have to
really keep the fire burning and uh
and get this debt knocked out means
you're going to be okay pastor you're
going to do great
thank you i appreciate that what's your
housewife i love you even more
uh 102 000. okay you're going to do fine
it gives me some hope here yeah it might
slow down the snowball if you're going
to save up during you know stork mode
and make sure baby's okay and all that
but
other than that you're going to pay off
this debt it's not going to delay you by
that much
yeah i was just concerned that the
shovel might have to be repurposed a
little bit it will it will but it's not
it's not a deal breaker and it's not
going to mean you're in debt a decade
longer it's going to mean you're in debt
four months longer
or something like that right whoopty
right whoopty babies are a big deal yeah
i'm just the dave guy that wants to be
out of debt yesterday so yeah well yeah
i i agree i agree uh
and
uh babies are the best thing you can do
so you know
uh they're they're you know it's a and
the
other second best thing the best thing
you can do is grand babies oh yeah if i
don't know how big great grand babies
are going to be i've been nicer to their
parents but yeah this is uh this is what
you ought to do for sure yeah absolutely
you have all the fun and spoil them
without having to load them up with
sugar send them home
or if you pick it up and say this one
smells bad hey this one smells bad
you're gonna have to break fix it this
one's broken diaper cheese i can't fix
this one
this one's got a problem take them
rachel that's so awesome just hand it
right back hey rachel come here get your
kid
yeah this is great it's fun it's a blast
yeah absolutely i love it but it's an
interesting concept because we usually
tell people stegazel intense but when it
comes to still living your life and
getting married we get that one a lot
too yeah should i wait to get married
because of debt should i be debt-free
before i'm married or should i you know
i have had people you know like i'm not
gonna marry him until he pays off all
his debt no
no i don't i don't want to marry you if
that's the case you know so
no that's not listen if if you're not in
agreement
then don't get married
but if you're in agreement
about we're going to get rid of this and
then we're going to build wealth and
we're going to work together
then you've got a marriage you know but
you don't have to wait till you're out
of debt to be married that's just
not true plan we're gonna work together
to accomplish these goals that's all it
is instead of a part
and you're actually gonna make more
progress and progress faster but yeah um
rachel was born the year we filed
bankruptcy so we don't uh we've never
planned babies around money um within
reason i mean again if it's an extreme
situation but but within reason
i um
i just don't put that as part of the
equation
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books good hour george nice job
kelly and jenna and ben in the booth the
booth people are lined up in there even
zach's in there this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna take your calls about your
relationships your work your career your
money
uh and your life it's all right here on
the ramsey show and we thank you for
joining us
there's about 22 million of you out
there thank you for that uh we are the
uh fifth largest podcast in the world
right now which is kind of mind-blowing
uh we're the second largest talk radio
show in north america
uh by any measure
and uh absolutely because of you guys
and we appreciate you we appreciate you
being there our youtube channel is uh
unbelievably successful we've got these
gold buttons and silver buttons around
here that mean we've had a bazillion
listeners and viewers there and
downloads and everything else all these
youtube awards and it's all because of
the numbers of you that are out there
and we're so honored by that and we
appreciate that
if you want to do us a favor
tell other people
that's the biggest favor you could do it
spread the word say hey listen to this
podcast listen this talk radio show
watch this on youtube and george and i
would would appreciate that and the
folks at ramsey would appreciate that
spread the word that's how life change
happens i found it takes a friend going
hey you got to check this out yeah check
this guy out and uh you know we'll do
the talking for you you don't have to
talk them into it we'll talk them into
it we'll wear them down baby we've been
doing it for 30 years that's right all
right evan is with us to start off this
hour in iowa hi evan welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave and george uh it's an honor to
speak with you both thanks for taking my
call and thanks so much for all you do
to help people well thank you what's up
uh so i uh about two years ago i started
to get after my debt i started with
eighty five thousand dollars in student
loan debt and uh right now today i'm at
fifty three thousand
um
and so after kind of getting on board
well definitely getting on board with
your principles about six months ago
um i realized that the mutual fund i
have of uh twenty thousand dollars i
need to cash out
um i cashed out five 000 of that at the
end of this past year
uh leaving 15 left in that mutual fund
and i was kind of waiting to see
um to get closer to the end of the
student loan pause to take the remainder
of that out but it's starting to dwindle
these past couple weeks with everything
that's going on
in the world and so i guess i'm just my
question is
should i pull it out right now it's at
13 000 or should i try to see if it's
going to go back up and recoup some of
the some of that loss
does that make sense
well if i'm in your shoes there's some
things i can control and one of those
things is not the economy and the stock
market but i can control paying down the
student loan debt as much as i can right
now and so i'm cashing it out because i
just don't know the future
okay
here's the swing evan okay
the the likelihood that that student
loan goes up ten percent in just a few
months is very low
ten percent in a year maybe
that wouldn't be unusual but ten percent
in a couple of months would be highly
unusual ten percent of thirteen thousand
is thirteen hundred dollars
we don't have a thirteen hundred dollar
discussion we have a fifty three
thousand dollar problem
thirteen hundred dollars one way or the
other does not make or break this
discussion
okay so what happens is i have the
feeling that's what you're gonna say
yeah i do this all the time and that's
why i recognize it when other people do
it here's what we do we start running
math numbers and we start looking at
percentages and we forget to look
and say okay there's a 53 000
problem
and i'm over here trying to manipulate
four dollars somewhere
or 1300 an insignificant amount of money
compared to the size of the problem
in order to somehow get an edge on this
problem where if i had taken that same
level of energy and said okay i'm going
to cut my budget i'm going to work six
jobs i'm going to not go out to eat i'm
not going on vacation i'm going to
completely focus on this problem and i'm
going to punch this 53 000 in the face
so many times that it just falls over
dead then
you know that's the deal and so the
secret sauce here evan is your
commitment and your energy and your
visceral response to this debt
that is 95 of your solution
five percent of your solution is math
manipulation
and so that that's what
i forget that because i'm a math nerd
and i'm always going to fix it with math
and most of the time it's not math it's
dave he's the problem on paper looks
great but then life happens so here's
what i'm seeing on paper if it helps you
out you've already paid off 32 000 in
debt yeah if you cash out the mutual
fund you're now down to 38. no no you
went from 85 to 53. so that's that's
about a 32. so he's got oh yeah he goes
down to 38. i'm sorry so then he'd go
down to 38. now i can see the light at
the end of the tunnel because he goes
yeah i've done this before three
thousand dollars a month you're done in
a year boom boom
and you start to go yeah yeah the
momentum and then you start finding that
money you say you know i go get that
different thing
i i change this around and that's how it
works so
that's the weird thing about personal
finance is it's usually not a math
problem
it's usually a focus and intentionality
problem
a sacrifice problem
a
commitment problem
it usually falls in those categories and
that that's what changes everything so
this that's just a great call evan it's
a really really
good question because it exposes the
things that most of us do where we place
our
our energies or our tr you know we that
we
we think something's a solution that's
not
and so it's like okay i you know i'm
going to refinance my credit cards from
18 down to 14. okay how much do you have
in credit card debt a thousand dollars
you just saved four dollars
sometimes you just changed your life you
know it's just you didn't say you might
why why did you can't even pay for the
stamp
to fix this i mean you probably wouldn't
use a stamp but oh my gosh you know i
mean it's just that that's wow but this
is a good it's a good point because with
the stock market investing when you're
up five percent ten percent you go i
gotta keep waiting and you start to get
a little bit a little bit greedy like
you're in vegas you're like well i'm up
i'm doing well let's keep riding this
thing out and see how it goes but that's
not the problem the problem is you
you're not making the extra percent the
problem is you're fifty three thousand
dollars in debt and the payments are
eating your life exactly so you got it
evan you got this and i'll you you and i
could tell by talking to you that you
got it and so i i predict good things
for you call us back with a debt free
screening it's coming it's coming your
way that's very cool
personal finance
is 80 behavior
it's only 20 percent had knowledge
that means that
here's how you become wealthy
it's 80
behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge the
mathematics of becoming a millionaire
sixth grade level
sixth grade level
it's called compound interest
it's not a calculus formula it's not a
trigonometry formula the pythagorean
theorem is not involved
what a waste of learning that was the
twerp in my mirror however
is the biggest issue if i can get that
boy to behave he can be skinny and rich
you'll get there we'll get there you go
you're one for two
too soon
you look great you're fired jordan okay
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard
go to netsuite.com ramsey right now to
get their free whitepaper jumpstart your
cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host if you're wondering whether to
buy or sell a home this year we've got
some answers you can expect the market
to be a lot like last year with prices
still on the rise but interest rates are
expected to go up too so what can you
make of all this well if you're buying a
home you might be up against some heavy
competition some big price tags and if
you want to sell your home chances are
it'll sell quickly for top dollar of
course this all depends on where you are
because every real estate market's
different but to win in any market you
really have to know what you're doing
this is not amateur hour
so you need to work with someone who
knows what they're doing you need an
experienced high octane high protein
real estate agent at your fingertips
and we've got that for you we've done
the vetting we've done the due diligence
and we've lined you up with endorsed
local providers as ramsey trusted pros
they care about your values
and they keep more money in your pocket
you're going to get the most for your
house if you're selling you're going to
not pay too much if you're buying
they're going to coach you walk with you
they know what they're doing in this
weird real estate world that we're in
today
check out ramseysolutions.com agent
we'll connect you with a ramsey trusted
pro who can help you navigate your local
market ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent
our question today comes from blinds.com
they're the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best possible deal today's question
comes from kim in arizona she says my
husband wants us to help his daughter
purchase her grandmother's home for
sixty thousand dollars his motivation
for doing this is he wants her to move
close to where we live
she was just let go from a job for
tardiness and has fourteen thousand
dollars in debt she just got back from
an expensive vacation and doesn't even
have enough for the down payment on this
house how can i convince him this is a
very bad idea
wow the art of persuasion that's it's a
difficult one i don't know that you can
convince him of anything it sounds like
he's made up his mind that his daughter
needs to have this house regardless of
her financial situation
which is a bad place to be so
kim knows this is a bad idea but she's
asking how do i get him on board with
the fact that this is not the time for
her to purchase this house
there is a few times in my life i have
been an enabler
but a whole bunch of times in my life
doing financial coaching i have run into
people who are enablers whether they're
enabling someone that's an addict or
they're enabling other bad behaviors
enablers
which your husband is kim
is
are the nicest
people they want to help
they're very sweet people if you're an
enabler i know this about you you're a
kind
gentle compassionate you're not a
grouchy person
you're a sweet person
because enablers always are they and
they always feel like they want to help
and he wants his daughter close to him
that's sweet and he wants to help his
little daughter and he's helped her a
lot over the years to the point that
she's basically useless
he's helped her so much that she has no
character she can't seem to show up at
work on time
she's a grown-up who can't even scrape
together the money for this i mean
you know he's
created a mess
and the thing the kim the only thing
i've ever been able to do with enablers
because they are convinced that they're
helping
and they are
helping people do the wrong things
uh and they're the sweetest people is i
just tell them i just say you know
you're so sweet
you need to realize though that when you
think you're helping
you're actually hurting
so honey i i don't think you should
bring harm to your daughter
i think you should love her enough to
not bring harm to her
and to participate in her craziness
to participate in her irresponsibility
and encourage it by financing it
is bringing harm to her
she needs to learn to keep a job by
showing up on time get her freaking work
done
and the fact that she can't do that is
because you've done this with her her
whole life because you've helped her so
much that she has no character
she has no bones
inside of her character
and so honey you're not helping you're
hurting
you're bringing harm to her
because you're not doing anything except
she's not gonna get better because you
did this
um now the goal is for her to live
closer to them and the grandmother and
the grandmother's home is in the deal
too so there's also some
sentimental value here emotion and
sentimental value so here's what we
could do
that i think would be good for uh his
daughter
is to say um
okay here's what we're gonna do
if you do these three things
i'm going to help you
but i'm not going to do them for you
unless you do these three things
one is you get four jobs and you start
working 60 hours to 80 hours a week you
will not die from hard work
just before you die from hard work you
pass out so you will not die from hard
work you're going to be okay that's
science it's it's science yeah and it's
brain science and so
you're going to be okay i want you and
number one number two you're gonna go
through financial peace university
and you're gonna graduate in a week
you're gonna binge watch the videos and
you're gonna go through them and we're
gonna discuss them together
um and number three with all the money
that you're making you're gonna save all
of it you're going to spend none of it
on stupid butt stuff because you need to
come up with a down payment really
really quick and if you do that for 60
days i'll help you get this house
but if you don't do that i'm not going
to help you get this house
and so what you're doing there is you're
encouraging her and you know i'll be mad
one more i'll pay off half of your debt
your fourteen thousand dollar debt
after you pay off the first half
get some stuff
i'll match you you put a thousand on it
i'll put a thousand on it you put two
thousand on it i'll put two thousand on
it until it's gone that gets where the
fourteen thousand dollars worth of debt
and then then we'll help you get
grandma's house but um but she's not
gonna be able to keep grandma's house
she's gonna lose grandma's house she's
gonna get foreclosed on if you go into
it this way so the only thing i've ever
been able the only way i've ever been
able to get an enabler to stop enabling
is to convince them that they're
actually bringing harm because an
enabler can't stand the idea that they
would be hurting someone because they're
sweet people
and if i can finally convince them that
they're causing harm rather than helping
that their version of help is actually
harmful
then um that's that's the deal sometimes
kicking someone's butts the best thing
you can do for them absolutely
absolutely especially if it's you know
it's moms and dads with grown kids in
their basement
i mean um
listen an eagle that doesn't leave the
nest eventually is known as a turkey
and so you you know you've got to help
them leave
for their sake
you're not helping them you're hurting
them you're bringing you've got a 36
year old in your basement you've brought
them harm
they're emotionally stunted in their
growth
their ability to function in the culture
is is stunted because you've you've
brought them harm and you thought you
were helping providing that you're still
continuing to do their laundry
you know and it's just and that's not
well dude that's tough love you're just
tough it's not tough love honey that's
love
it's love to allow people to live out
their best life create a sustainable
situation with dignity that's empowering
that's love that's real love yeah
and uh you know toxic love is i'm going
to keep you around so i feel better
and let me continue your misbehavior
that's enable that's enabler language
what about what about this plan what if
she could rent grandma's home
since she's broke
and eventually it can be hers well
depends on who she's renting it from i
don't know the ownership level we don't
have that information that if dad has to
buy it and rent it to her that's about
she's not going to pay the payment and
then he's not going to throw her out
because now we're just we're just
expecting your daughter that's awkward
well we just it is awkward but you're
also setting her up to lose
because she knows she's not going to pay
the payment she knows he's a pushover
an enabler
same thing and yeah so she she knows
this and so she knows exactly where they
stand so no you can't you can't put her
in there with him as the backstop
because him backstopping her has been
the issue but but you know the truth is
kim
your husband is a kind nice man
he really is a good person
he's sweet he really is a sweet person
and i'm not making fun i'm not being
sarcastic i really do think he is
he has just defined
the word help
wrong his definition of help is not
accurate
you're not helping you're harming when
you give a drunk
a drink you didn't help the drunk
you feel better because you feel like
you did something and you thought you
were nice and you didn't create conflict
but you didn't help you brought harm
when a drunk continues
to be enough to be a drunk because you
helped that's the definition of harm
toxic generosity that's what it is
that's a definition of harm this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage seth
and kristen are with us welcome guys hi
good to have you guys where do you guys
live elkton tennessee about
45 minutes south of here on the
tennessee alabama border down towards
huntsville yeah very cool well welcome
to nashville you not not not a bad drive
up at all no actually it probably took
you less than if you'd driven from
nashville yeah i work here so oh okay
even easier all right welcome how much
debt have you guys paid off about a
hundred thousand very good how long did
this take you um longer than it should
have and that was my fault
um it took about four and a half years
um when we first got married
we got
really intense we got rid of the credit
cards we didn't have any debt or
anything um we both took side hustles
working at a pumpkin farm for somebody
that we knew and paid off his car good
um and then we um we worked for the next
year and paid off my student loans
and then after that we were kind of
ish for about two years
um he kept saying oh what's your foot
off the gas yes he's like we need to do
a budget we need to do a budget i'm like
no
we live on less than we make we save
some each month why do we need a budget
and um so then eventually she saw yeah
eventually well then covet hit and
i was um i'm a pediatric speech
pathologist and our clinic was shut down
for two months
and i was pregnant and so then by the
time we opened back up i was on
maternity leave so i was out of work for
several months and so
um
after kind of everything started opening
up again you had an event here called
what now yeah
and we came to that yeah you were in the
studio audience we were only a couple
hundred people down there yeah yes yeah
and so we went home that night paid for
the every dollar budget
and we got on board and as soon as i
went back to work it was like game on
okay you finish it up then all right
we got you back on track i like it yes
yeah the pandemic was the wake up call
it was it was
wow i'm proud of y'all it's done
it's sometimes it's harder to return to
something than it is just go all the way
through it it was a little bit hard at
first but
i mean using the every dollar app
literally made a difference i mean we
tried the cash envelopes but we do
grocery pickup and stuff that don't take
cash and so it was harder to stay on
budget for us that way with the every
dollar app oh my goodness
you're now like an evangelist but right
before that you were saying i was like
we don't need to do a budget we live on
less than we make what was her favorite
things i know i'm confused what was the
turning point for you it was well it was
we looked at how much we made each month
and it was like why are we not able to
save more why are we not saving more and
putting more towards a debt than what we
do
and so um
finally it was like okay we did the
budget we made it so that we lived
completely off his paycheck because i
went down to part time after we had our
son we're going to send her to congress
she can straighten them out
get them on every dollar budget she
could straighten them out i could common
dadgum sense i like it well done very
good good for you guys
so cool so cool how does it feel to be
free
really good yes
so the last thing to go with sally mae
you gave her her eviction papers we did
yes we got rid of both of our student
loans and we got rid of um that car that
was the first thing so yeah we got a new
car just recently pay cash for it you're
right i like it yeah i think your name
is a cuss word and car dealerships i
think it is did you bring it up i gotta
know oh yes yeah yeah sweet i got really
really dirty looks like oh boy
well they were you know they got
confused that you were the customer with
the money i don't understand yeah they
were they were not wanting to come down
on the price that we were willing to pay
and we were like they're like we'll just
finance the rest and we're like we don't
do that we follow dave ramsey
that was their sign that we are not
making money off of these people that's
why they were angry yeah yeah i love it
that's fun that's cool what'd you buy
what kind of car mazda 3.
sweet good for you i'm proud of you guys
well done all right now that you did it
you you uh started you let your foot off
the gas then you got back on and knocked
it out what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is uh don't give
up
i mean
murphy is gonna hit it's gonna happen it
happened to us last year i mean it was
like
we had saved up enough money to pay off
his student loans had half of our
emergency fund and then we had a big
plumbing repair
his other car went out and we ended up
having to buy another car and it was
just like
boom boom boom but we paid cash for all
those things and we just kept going it
was like okay this set us back a couple
months but we can still do it amen
now you have a lot less emergencies now
that you're not broke it's yeah it's
funny i mean once we had the emergency
fund in place it was like murphy stopped
bothering us
he went next door
odd thing that works that way i like it
very well done okay so you brought the
baby with you we did yes
and we're actually expecting another one
all right
and so this is uh what is his name and
how old is he colin sanders this is
colin he's 22 months all right and then
this is ray she is due in august all
right i love it you guys are amazing i'm
so proud of you very well done we got a
copy of the baby steps millionaires book
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you're heading that way
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too also a copy total
money makeover you can give that to
somebody they start hearing about your
story they're going to want to do this
and you can show them how to do it that
way and get it get it moving way to go
you guys who was your biggest
cheerleader outside the two of you um i
would say our families our families were
very supportive um i mean i grew up in a
family
they didn't exactly follow the dave plan
but they knew i mean they were good with
finances and everything um but they
still use credit cards i'm working on
them
[Laughter]
way to go you two proud of you very well
done all right it's seth and kristen and
colin huntsville alabama area uh
southern tennessee to be exact a hundred
thousand paid off in four and a half
years what a great story count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
way to go you guys
way to go
that's amazing i love that
anyone can transform even the budget
haters they can learn to love the budget
more than that i'll be an evangelist for
it amazing i mean love it that's you're
right that's fabulous the best pitch for
the budget is keep more of your money
there it is once you figure that out she
said we're working too hard where's our
money going we can keep more of this if
we do the budget if we make the money
behave that we have that's exactly right
very well done good stuff roth is with
us in uh where is this uh alaska
yeah homer alaska all right good stuff
let's see here where's the button there
it is hey roth what's up
hey dave it's uh william ralph i just uh
a commercial fisherman i grew up fishing
and owned
been riding my own boat since i was 18
i'm 25 right now and
i
i've done a bad thing and upgraded boats
so i went from a 40-foot boat to a
56-foot boat but i had to borrow another
100 000 on it
so my business debt is at 200 and my
house debt so i vote mortgages at 200
000 and my
house mortgage is at 120 and
i'm wondering which do i pay off first
vote
pay off the boat first yep
yep what are you making what's your net
profit a year
it varies because it's fishing i know
some years are 200 and other years
they're like 50.
really
yeah it can it can really vary a lot uh
we've had more
steady years as things have kind of
leveled off also so what do you think
you're going to make in the coming year
what would you guess you're going to
make next year
i plan on making 100 in the following
year here and with the bigger boat i
also expect an increase year to year
more steady as well
okay
yeah you need to live on nothing man get
this boat paid off this thing's got you
vulnerable
you're you're in a really risky
situation
really risky uh
so the boat is what i would tackle first
and what's your uh what's your reasoning
behind that
because it is a huge destabilizer for
your business this was a stupid move
and if you get if you get in a sideways
and a cash flow problem here that this
200 000 boat debt is going to take you
out
and so i want to get rid of that the
house won't take you out this will take
you out
and it's the risk that's scaring me and
there's a lot more risk than you
perceive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today first corinthians 2
9 no eye has seen nor ear has heard and
no human mind has conceived the things
god has prepared
for those who love him
anne frank said what a wonderful thought
it is
that some of the best days of our lives
haven't even happened yet
ah i like that
very cool that's true if all your good
days are in the past you're uncle rico
just reliving the memories there you go
do a little napoleon dynamite
just in case just in case somebody
wondered all right hunter is in austin
texas hey hunter how are you
doing good dave god bless you and what
you guys do there thank you sir how can
we help
need some wisdom from you on short-term
investment a little back story quickly
my wife and i sold our home
after 10 years here in the austin area
and as you know it's a great market and
so we
took an offer we couldn't pass up so
question is we immediately put our
windfall
into a cd
that comes up to term june 1st and uh
we're just biding our time for a little
bit until we find a plot of land where
we want to build the next house we have
no outstanding debt and we own all of
our vehicles so where should we park
that sucker for the next 24 months or so
well there's uh you're gonna make
nothing but lose nothing
if you keep it parked in
you know high-yield cds or something but
they don't they don't even pay one
percent so it's a bit of a joke it's
like free parking yeah six tenths of a
percent yeah it's just free parking
we're just gonna park it here
and uh we're not making anything but
we're not losing anything
and if you want to take a little bit
more risk than that obviously you can
move some of it towards the market
but with the world uh
in in upheaval
it's a weird time to be playing market
short term
i don't mind playing it long term i'm
not pulling anything out because of the
world
in up evil but parking stuff for 18 or
24 months you might lose some money you
know
and so you know you got to be willing to
take that risk in order to make a little
bit of money
so it's just a matter of do you want to
trade some risk for some money
uh
potentially uh or do you want to just be
you know real calm and just park it
there's not a wrong answer um how much
money is involved
175 000 okay all right
and so if you lost 10 percent you'd lose
17 000
yeah
that would not keep you from building
the house
no if you made 10
you'd make 17 000
and that's probably your that's probably
your over and under
right
would it yeah
to your point what what would you
recommend you talking about index funds
like yeah i mean i'll just drop it into
an index fund an s p 500 index fund i do
that because i but but the the
difference is it doesn't mean
i'm i can't build the house you know
because of it or something and and so i
can i can it's not going to mat in my
case
i'll give you an example what i would be
parking personally money in there for
for a short term like that would be i'm
parking it there until i find a piece of
real estate i want to buy
okay and so if i'm buying a a an
expensive piece of real estate a 5 or a
10 swing one way or the other
i'm not going to know within that what
i'm going to pay for the real estate
because it's not a certain piece of real
estate it's not a certain target so it
doesn't matter if i make a little or
lose a little i and i just do it just
because i'd rather not make six tenths
of a percent but it but it's also
if it's gonna steal your joy
if you lose ten thousand dollars
um
you know then then just put it in a
money market put in a cd it's not that
big a deal
you're not gonna get rich because of
this move
and you're not going to go broke because
of this move that's my point you know so
i i you know just get kind of gauge out
you know how you and your wife feel
uh i can tell you sharon uh would
probably park in the cd my wife probably
would
just because she doesn't want to think
about it
and me i don't think about it
when i put it in the index fund so it's
okay either way you got to take into
account how much anxiety is this going
to cost
watching it go up and down up and down
each day versus going you know what if
it's going to cause you to to watch the
stock market and you usually don't then
don't do it yeah then don't do it but
i've got you know i've done this before
when we were saving up for our house and
i remember you're kind of going oh gosh
i hope when i pull it out it went up and
you have that feeling of oh gosh am i
going to lose money on this and so if
you really need it by a certain time and
it's a short timeline i like just
parking it in the high yield savings
account and calling it a day yeah it's
that that works 100 of the time
and no anxiety which we could all use
less
and 100 of the time you're making no
money so it's it's okay there's nothing
wrong with that that's that's the
purpose of it so good stuff sarah is in
chicago hi sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thank you
so i started your program two years ago
and i have managed to pay off about 43
000 so far
i took on a side job this year to get
that going and unfortunately i always
say i did not do the correct deductions
and now i have a four thousand dollar
tax bill due oh
yes so my question is is twofold one how
do i make sure this doesn't happen again
when the position i'm working is
commission based
and two um
do i
use my thousand dollar
emergency fund to go towards this and
is there like an extension how do you
what are you making
what kind of money do you make um
on the side job period or just in portal
both
uh 86
000
that's like that's combined
that was combined yeah okay
all right um
okay let's pretend that your hair is on
fire
because that's what owing the irs money
is
and so we're going to go completely
bananas
between now and april 15th and we're
going to find four thousand dollars
okay you haven't filed your taxes yet
right
no i just started them last night and
then that's how i found out wow yeah
what happened here yeah okay i also may
work with a tax pro because they can
really help you bring down that tax bill
and so they'll make you the money back
that they cost you that's probably true
yeah and to avoid in the future
quarterly estimated payments is what you
want to be making if you've got those
side hustles because i've been there and
that's something i learned along the way
was oh that helps to pay them something
and you want to get as close as you can
so you got to be socking away 25 30
percent of that freelance side hustle
income so that you don't have to deal
with this again yeah so when you make a
thousand bucks on your side hustle you
set 250 aside
for taxes
you withhold on yourself that's what
george is saying okay and then you're
supposed to file a one-page piece of
paper once a quarter called a quarterly
estimate and it's your estimated taxes
and you're supposed to go ahead and make
the deposit for those estimated taxes
and then that way what amounts to is you
would have put a thousand dollars a
quarter aside last year and so you would
have been at break even
right if you had done that last year so
that's how you keep from that happening
this year as far as this you cannot file
an extension on taxes you owe you can
file in extensions on the
filing of the tax return but the taxes
are still due on april 15th and if you
don't pay them you're going to be
penalized and uh and have interest at it
as well and so i'm going to pay every
dollar you can pay even if you pay 3 600
and you only get penalized on 400
okay
so you pay as much as you can scrape
together you scrape everything together
just as hard as you can go and you go on
beans and rice and you i mean you go
bananas between now and april 15th and
get a tax bro to help you calculate this
it'll be worth it silver lining is april
18th so extra three days this year dave
she gets to save up that's helpful
sarcasm thank you george
yeah uh check
ramseysolutions.com and click an elp for
taxes and they'll sit down with you help
you do this
and even if your taxes are fairly simple
in your case we want to make really
really sure and they can help you set
those quarterly estimates up too
uh so that you can learn how to do that
it's not complicated it's not that hard
to do but uh but but having somebody
show you how to do it the first time is
not a bad idea it's worth a little bit
of expense for professional fees to do
that and they may know some deductions
that you can take from your side hustle
which will reduce
your taxable income on the side hustle
because basically your side hustle is
self-employed income probably going to
be filed on a schedule c
on your tax return
and they may know some things you can
put in there that george and i wouldn't
know because we're not very good at
taxes so there we go
good stuff that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books thanks to
george campbell to kelly to ben to jenna
to zach to everybody in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you